bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine foot
ball trap qui évolue en ph a créé
l'exploit en coupe de france contre le
paris sia l'équipe de dsr les trappistes
ont arraché la victoire aux tirs au but
après avoir égalisé la dernière minute
du temps réglementaire reportage à
suivre
course à pied la 39e édition de paris
versailles est organisée ce dimanche
plus de 25 mille coureurs professionnels
ou amateurs ont participé à cette
compétition
plus de détails dans cette édition
découverte mousseau nous avons testé le
pilotage sur circuit le pilote
professionnel stéphane panepinto nous
présentera ses astuces et techniques
pour courir en compétition mais gros
plans tout de suite sur les résultats du
week end
les pronostics les donnait perdants et
pourtant les joueurs de trappes en aussi
abattre le pari c'est en coupe de france
une équipe qui évolue deux divisions au
dessus des saint quentinois le score 2
buts partout et victoire 5 à 4 aux tirs
au but un reportage de semaine van der
velde
c'est dans la douleur que l'équipe de
trappes s'est imposé hier face au paris
ca
et pourtant le match avait mal débuté
mené tout au long de la rencontre par
l'équipe adverse les trappistes ont tenu
bon
on a de la fierté c'est une belle
victoire
on revient deux fois au score bon ça
qu'on reconnaît un mental on a des
choses à corriger mais c'est
encourageant pour la suite
ça prouve qu'on s'est pas foulé ces on
revient deux fois au score rapidement on
se fait mener on a une belle équipe un
bon mental et ça va nous servir pour
leurs glaciers et c'est grâce à cette
force et cette cohésion d'équipé que le
strap a pu revenir au score à la
dernière minute du temps réglementaire
et ensuite maîtrisé cette séance de tirs
au but
enfin l'équipe de la chaire k car façon
jeu on a été patient et arraché deux
donations faites en bout de course parce
qu'on l'a pas lâché que c'est bon esprit
qui va je m'en lave encore ils
connaîtront leurs futurs adversaires
pour le prochain tour de la coupe de
france ce mardi 27 septembre à 18 heures
en attendant le est scrap se focalise
sur le championnat de ph
d'autres équipes se sont qualifiées pour
ce 5e tour de la coupe de france
versailles qui évolue en dh a réussi à
dominer assez facilement sa mort l'une
des meilleures équipes de cfa le score
est sans appel 4 à 0 menthe s'est
facilement imposé contre salisienne de
paris 4 à 0 l'aventuré s'arrête en
revanche pour guyancourt qui n'a pas
démérité contre drancy club de cfa mais
qui s'inclinent 1 à 0 l'un des petit
poucet yvelinois de cette coupe de
france vélizy n'a pas pu réaliser
l'exploit contre champigny le résultat
est sans appel 5 à 1 du ballon rond on
passe au ballon ovale de nombreux
matches étaient programmés à ce week-end
dans les yvelines en fédérale 2 plaisir
recevez le havre à l'occasion de la 2e
journée les joueurs de jean mi se sont
facilement imposés 30 à 7 contre les
normands et enregistrent leur deuxième
victoire de la saison
un résultat qui leur permet d'occuper la
deuxième place derrière le favori de la
poule
ris orangis
ont joué également dans le championnat
honneur versailles qui descend de
fédérale 3 s'est fait surprendre à
l'extérieur contre man clim et sur le
score de 21 à 7
à l'occasion de la première journée au
classement versailles pour le moment
avant dernier ex-aequo avec vitry faudra
faire plus pour réussir remonter dès
cette année enfin pour terminer cette
page
rugby le sky jouer ce dimanche dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur
pas de souci pour les saint quentinois
ils sont allés battre noisy-le-sec à
l'extérieur sur le score de 24 à 6 une
victoire qui leur permet déjà de prendre
la première place du classement à
égalité de points avec chilly mazarin le
sky espère monter en honneur cette
saison
il y avait également de la course à pied
ce week-end avec le paris versailles ce
16km fêtait cette année sa 39e édition
25000 courant passait la ligne d'arrivée
près du château de versailles
les images ont signé à nicolas quere le
médecin la grande classique du paris
versailles a fait le plein une nouvelle
fois cette année la course à pied de 16
km entre la tour eiffel le château de
versailles a attiré plus de 25000
personnes pour sa 39e édition c'est sur
une aussi belle cause mais aujourd'hui
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de chance à cause
de la pluie
on est parti sous soleil arrivée sous la
pluie mais c'est toujours une belle
course à faire arriver dans cette belle
ville de versailles et le parcours est
magnifique
il ya du monde surtout parcours qui nous
encouragent qui nous encourageons passe
dans les bois c'est vraiment la
principale difficulté de ce circuit se
situer sur la côte des gars de meudon un
secteur avec 170 m de dénivelé on le
savait au 5e kilomètre à la cote des
gardes qui dure 2 kilomètres mais après
c'est quand même une mois
une succession de montées descentes donc
ça casse bien les jambes et sur la
france et c'est dur de ces dures
d'activer les cinq premiers kilomètres
très facile comme d'habitude la cause la
beauté de la garde et qui est complexe à
gérer faut savoir au lancer derrière et
après ce que du plaisir faut savoir
déroulé le kenyan stephen hough harry a
remporté l'épreuve en 49 minutes et 59
secondes il a devancé le burundais
abraham niyonkuru de 17 secondes
chez les féminines l'éthiopienne ou
woldu a terminé en 55 minutes et 19
secondes du cyclisme sur piste à présent
les championnats du monde masters
débutent ce samedi à manchester une
dizaine de pisteur de l'équipe de france
se déplaceront pour l'épreuve
le dernier rassemblement s'est tenu ce
samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à xavier
jaillard pour le montage dernier
entraînement pour l'équipe de france
masters ce avant les championnats du
monde les pistards âgés de plus de 35
ans ont pu mettre en place l'homme
technico bel automne national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en vue de la
compétition qui se tiendra à partir de
ce samedi jusqu'au dimanche 8 octobre à
manchester en angleterre
normalement le groupe est prêt
normalement voilà ces sont les derniers
réglages à effectuer vu que comme on
vous le disait tout à l'heure ils
viennent de toute la france
on a des aquitains on a des jambes
bretagne voilà donc il faut faire les
réglages on particulièrement pour les
épreuves par équipes
l'entraînement des dix coureurs s'est
déroulée sous les yeux du parrain de la
section master's quentin lafargue
champion de france de vitesse 2015 et
double médaillé de bronze aux
championnats du monde et s'est laissé
leur faire profiter de deux
mon expérience du haut niveau actuel
pour pouvoir alors permettre de les
aider à avancer après on a chacun nos
calendriers et je suis pas ultra présent
il frapperait d'emplois mais mais je
trouve quoi ils s'organisent ils
s'organisent pas mal et puis cette cime
ces petits malades la gueule quand même
aux derniers championnats du monde la
france avait décroché trois médailles
dont un titre en individuel
le team master's espère améliorer cette
performance cette année en terre
britannique direction à présent le
circuit jean-pierre beltoise de trappes
nous avons testé le pilotage avec une
voiture de sport le pilote professionnel
stéphane à peine pinto originaire de
guyancourt nous présente ses astuces et
techniques pour courir en compétition au
regard des alors aujourd'hui c'est une
journée à un petit peu particulière nous
allons tester les techniques de pilotage
pour tester ces techniques nous sommes
avec le pilote mini montain ce n'est pas
les pinto qui a notamment participé aux
world series maserati bonjour ce n'est
pas d'elle alors qu'elle est programme
aujourd'hui et demain on va prendre
quelques pilotage la base au plus qu'à
et puis pour ce faire on a une belle rs3
de 367 chevaux cinq cylindres quatre
roues motrices
autant dire que y'a de quoi faire et ne
pas faire ça va ça va envoyer c'est un
petit peu peur vous allez vous rassurer
on vers un site de faire peur super à
léonie verte est parti
ce soir
sa guise
alors les points de braquage il faut
savoir qu'un virage on aborde toujours à
l'extérieur toujours à l'extérieur
toujours à l'extérieur on vient chercher
donc le point de braquage d'accord le
braquage des signifiés par des plots
jaunes sur la chance ce sont ces
circuits
ils sont les points de blocage sont
balisés les points de corde et les
points de sortie également
donc là on arrive sur la chicane on peut
apercevoir le plot jaune qui correspond
à notre point de braquage gars qui
ajusta gaulle à sa gauche
là on rentre chicane pour aborder une
grande courbe à droite
donc moi je sais qu'elle tourne à droite
donc je me place tout de suite à gauche
extérieur du dans un violon
obligatoirement passer sur l'extérieur
pour vos entrées vers l'intérieur il va
prendre à l'intérieur alors le but c'est
qu'on peut voir sur ces images c'est
d'avoir le volant le plus droit possible
dans un virage lent vaccine courbe en
temps mon volant n'est pas vraiment
braquer et le but de cette cet exercice
c'est de pouvoir imposer un minimum de
contraintes à la voiture de golf minimum
deux rames plus on a le volant braqué
plus on freine la voiture
c'est parti ces parties tuent à nous
montrer donc c'était bien retenu jeu se
voit alors là on prend aux le point de
braquage freine quand braquage et on va
le co2 suivent à chercher ton point de
corde qui est au milieu du virage est
élargie tout de suite le ton violent
élargi pourrait chercher ton point de
sortir on le voit comme un réflexe tu
arrives tu à puces table dans la
oui c'est mieux c'est mieux c'est pas
encore ça
c'est mieux mais ça c'est normal étais
tu vas pas prendre ma place en trois
tours
merci beaucoup pour son pilotage c'est à
toi de consultation du coup c'est quand
tout le monde c'est pour tout le monde
et cette technique de freinage et
d'anticipation sont utiles pour la route
il arrive en parler lors de son circuit
mais il faut aussi penser à la route
anticiper tout ce que vous faites ce que
les autres font et le freinage penser à
freiner arrêtez votre voiture est à
avoir le prince harry fait on doit avoir
le plus vite possible
ok ces femmes merci et à bientôt à très
bientôt au revoir merci
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du
week-end
on commet cet agenda part du baseball
les cougars de montier bretons ne
l'était à saint-just-saint-rambert le
week-end dernier pour jouer la finale
des playoffs
je vous rappelle la formule cinq matches
sont programmés la première équipe à
trois victoires remportent la série
après ce premier rang de ce premier week
end les deux équipes sont à égalité 1
partout le retour est programmé ce
samedi à 16 heures et dimanche à 11
heures au stade jean maréchal de
montigny on écoute l'un des joueurs de
l'équipe des cougars alexandre couton
mes concurrents il conclu
on a montré qu'on était en recul depuis
les cours mon campement que marivaux
rajouter montigny-le-bretonneux n'a pas
évolué en première division depuis la
saison 2012 un autre rendez vous à ne
pas manquer à ce week-end en handball
féminin montier montre ne reçoit bové ce
samedi à 20h30 à l'occasion de la 3e
journée du championnat de nationale 2
les deux équipes affichent toutes les
deux un bilan de 8 victoires et une
défaite depuis le début de la saison
la rencontre est programmée au palais
des sports de maurepas on termine à cet
agenda part du rugby la division honneur
à versailles qui a concédé sa première
défaite de la saison contre nantes ce
week-end aura l'occasion de se rattraper
ce dimanche sur son terrain contre
bagneux une équipe à emporter l'équipe a
remporté son premier match contre
vincennes versailles doit impérativement
l'emporter pour espérer remonter dès
cette saison en fédérale 3 c'est la fin
de cette fuite sport merci de l'avoir
suivi je retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive